en el vídeo anterior teníamos una
situación en la que estaba una pendiente
hecha de hielo teníamos encima un bloque
con hielo y aquí calculamos o bueno
vimos que la fuerza de gravedad estaba
actuando sobre este bloque y la
descompusimos en sus elementos paralelos
y verticales para conocer pues cuáles
serán las fuerzas que estaban actuando
aquí calculamos que el valor de la
fuerza o el componente perpendicular de
esta fuerza de gravedad era de 49 x raíz
de 3 newtons y la fuerza en la
componente paralela era de 49 minutos
también vimos que bueno hay un algo que
evita que este bloque se hunda dentro de
esta pendiente y es una fuerza que
compensa o equilibra totalmente esta
componente perpendicular pero va en
sentido opuesto esta fuerza es una
fuerza que está pendiente ejerce sobre
el bloque y evita que esta segunda a
esta fuerza la llamamos la fuerza normal
que es opuesta a la componente de la
fuerza de gravedad pero con la
componente paralela no tenía contraparte
o al menos así lo vimos en el vídeo
anterior y encontramos que esta
componente paralela es de 49 newtons y
si no habían otras fuerzas pues el
bloque se aceleraría hacia abajo en esta
dirección para calcular la aceleración
dividimos esta fuerza entre la masa del
bloque
si el bloque está estacionario que es lo
que debería estar pasando
si no se está acelerando las fuerzas
netas de este bloque pues deben estar
compensándose vamos a imaginar entonces
otra situación vamos a imaginar que este
bloque y está estacionario y este bloque
en lugar de estar hecho de hielo va a
estar hecho de madera
aquí está hecho de madera
entonces bueno si este bloque está
estacionario debe haber una fuerza que
se está compensando esta fuerza paralela
y está aquí ya la agregue en este color
azul fuerte esta fuerza que evita que se
mueva el bloque que está compensando
esta fuerza paralela en este sentido se
llama fuerza de fricción y es
exactamente el mismo valor de la fuerza
paralela de la gravedad solo que va en
sentido opuesto
entonces
esta fuerza de fricción de 49 newtons
pues bueno está existiendo ahora en esta
nueva situación en la que tengo un
bloque de madera en lugar de un bloque
de hielo creo que ustedes saben por
experiencia cuál es la diferencia entre
tener un bloque de madera sobre una
superficie de hielo o una pendiente de
hielo y un bloque de hielo encima de
hielo en este último caso pues el bloque
se va a deslizar porque no existe
fricción en cambio si hay fricción con
la madera y pues podemos imaginar que
esa superficie podemos poner una madera
o una lija o algo similar pues para
hacerlo más claro la fuerza que evita el
deslizamiento de las siete situaciones
la fuerza de fricción y la fuerza de
fricción siempre va a actuar en el
sentido contrario o opuesto al
movimiento
bueno entonces aquí tenemos que esta
fuerza es exactamente igual a mi fuerza
de gravedad
esto lo podemos resolver
experimentalmente si tenemos aparatos
que puedan medir la fuerza que se está
aplicando aquí una pregunta interesante
sería que tanto tengo que empujar este
bloque para que éste comience a
deslizarse hacia abajo
digamos que experimentalmente pueden
aplicar un newton de fuerza sobre este
bloque hacia abajo entonces vamos a
imaginar que aquí estamos aplicando un
newton
de fuerza hacia abajo
y con esto podemos decir que bloque
apenas comience a moverse yo a esto voy
a llamarlo fuerza agregada aunque es un
término inventado no se lo van a
encontrar en una clase de física
entonces esta fuerza agregada
va a ir en esta dirección para paralela
de la fuerza paralela y va a ser la
fuerza que ya tengo debido a la gravedad
más un newton que yo apliqué voy a tener
que mi fuerza agregada es de 50 minutos
y by pues en esta dirección paralela a
la pendiente
la razón entre la fuerza agregada o la
magnitud de esta fuerza y la fuerza
normal de hecho lo voy a escribir aquí
la magnitud de esta fuerza agregada o
este término inventado
qué es la fuerza suficiente para
comenzar a mover el bloque si esto lo
divido
entre la magnitud de la fuerza normal
este valor
fuerza normal de hecho vamos a ponerle
valores mi fuerza normal aquí es de 49 x
raíz de 3 newtons y mi fuerza
agregadas su magnitud
es de 50 minutos
esta razón me va a dar una cantidad que
se llama
coeficiente de fricción
estática porque se está estacional
esto no se es
coeficiente
d
fricción disculpen la letra aquí no se
me facilita escribir muy bonito de
ficción estática
ok 3 fuerza de fricción estática
este es un coeficiente de fricción no va
a tener unidades de hecho si hacemos
esta operación nos va a dar el valor de
0.59 no tiene unidades porque son newton
sobre newtons esto se cancela y este
coeficiente lo podemos usar o lo vamos a
usar en otros vídeos con objetos
estacionarios y con objetos en
movimiento en algunos materiales este
valor o este coeficiente de fricción
cambia cuando se tiene el objeto
detenido o estacionario a cuando está en
movimiento y esto lo vamos a ver en los
siguientes vídeos